we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting voicemail in that it says i
shouldn't really worry too much about
those who are trying to continue
defending the use and pushing the use of
fossil fuels because it's going to
naturally resolve itself but in a
slightly different way than we usually
hear from people let's take a listen to
this voicemail and david you should you
shouldn't be so worried about the
climate deal with trump and the things
he's doing because we are about ten
years from renewables overtaking they
will be it'll be cheaper than oil we're
less than ten years away from that
they're the oil people their days are
numbered
so yeah renewables are gonna catch up
and surpass oil in the next decade
there's no sense getting too worked up
about it i disagree and here's why i
don't disagree that there's no question
that in a free market renewables would
surpass would overtake and surpass
fossil fuels in the next ten years the
problem is we don't actually have a free
market of energy ideas for lack of
calling it something else we have a
situation where the government continues
to subsidize dirty non-renewable fossil
fuels so even if you are right that
within ten years fossil fuels should
naturally sort of go away and be
replaced with renewables it's not clear
that that's going to happen because you
have some of the most oil-rich nations
dictating policy lobbying for subsidies
on these dirty destructive types of
energy you have a a sort of absence of
those same advantages being afforded to
the purveyors of alternative energy
other than you know so you do have
something like the electrical car
federal tax credit in the united states
although Donald Trump is threatening to
take that away so what you're saying
would be accurate if you didn't have a
concerted effort from the American and
other governments to prop up
artificially fossil fuel use and that's
why we need to be doing something about
it and we should be worked up about it
on the bonus show today
homelessness up for the second year in a
row according to a new federal report we
will talk about that Miss Universe has
its first transgender contestant while
Miss USA is ramping up criticism of that
and we will also talk about giraffes
silently being placed on the endangered
list of animals facing extinction all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show two ways to get access to that
bonus show become a member
become a patron and most recently way
number three starting this week we have
multiple tiers of YouTube membership
which will also give you access to the
bonus show all of those options all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show look forward to seeing you there